ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
TODAY'S TUESDAY MARCH FIFTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. WE'LL GET
STARTED IN JUST A MINUTE WE DO
NOT HAVE A QUORUM SO WE'LL START
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE. AND JUST SOME
OF THE TECHNICAL AND PRACTICAL
ISSUES BEFORE WE GET STARTED.
WELL THEY'RE NO MORE CAPACITY
LIMITS WERE PHYSICAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS BASS REQUIREMENTS
AT CENTER FOR OUR HEARINGS WE
STILL ARE UNDER THE PANDEMIC SO
WE ARE. ASKING FOLKS TO BE SMART
ABOUT DISTANCING AND BEING
CAREFUL SO THAT WE ARE NOT
FACILITATING UNDUE SPREAD OF THE
DISEASE ANY FURTHER THAN WE HAVE
TO. WE DO HAVE TWO DIFFERENT
OPTIONS FOR WITNESSES TODAY WE
ARE. BACK IN. MORE OR LESS
NORMAL MODE WHAT EVER THAT IS OR
WAS. AND WITNESSES CERTAINLY CAN
PRESENT HERE IN THE ROOM BUT
ALSO FOR THIS COMMITTEE WERE
LLOWING WITNESSES TO COMMENT
TELEPHONICALLY. FOR ANY MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WANTS
TO TESTIFY ON THE BILL IN
ADDITION TO THE WITNESSES THEN
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME PLEASE
COME UP AND APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. THAT REGULAR
WITNESSES WILL BE UP AT THE AT
THE TABLES WE STILL ASK THAT
FOLKS NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE
TO LET THE SERGEANTS MANAGE THAT
FOR YOU. FOR THE MEMBERS OF
PUBLIC WHO ARE WISHING TO
COMMENT TELEPHONICALLY. THE
PUBLIC TOLL FREE NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN. AGAIN THAT'S
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE. FIVE SEVEN THAT
SHOULD BE UP FOR THOSE WATCHING
ONLINE. THAT SHOULD BE UP ON THE
SCREEN ABOUT NOW WHERE YOU CAN
CHECK THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE FOR
IT THE ACCESS CODE WILL BE ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN.
AGAIN THAT'S. ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR THREE SEVEN. PLEASE WAIT TO
YOUR BILL ITEM IS UP. WE WILL
ASK FOR PROPONENTS AND THEN
OPPONENTS GENERALLY IN THAT
ORDER SO IT IS HELPFUL IF YOU DO
CALL IN OR YOU FOLLOW THE
PROCESS. AT THE DESIGNATED TIME
. ALL RIGHT WE WILL. WORK AS A
SUB COMMITTEE THAN FIRST UP
TODAY OUR ITEM NUMBER ONE IS AJ
ARE TWENTY THREE. MS BERGER
HARBATH. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS AGE ARE
TWENTY THREE WOULD RECOGNIZE THE
FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF TITLE
NINE PROTECTIONS AGAINST SEX-BASED DISCRIMINATION IN SCHOOLS
I WOULD URGE CALIFORNIA TO
CONTINUE TO WORK TOGETHER TO
ACHIEVE ITS GOAL OF A MORE EQUAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OUR YOUTH
TITLE MY PROHIBITS SEX
DISCRIMINATION A GROUP INCLUDING
PREGNANCY SEXUAL ORIENTATION AND
GENDER IDENTITY IN ANY EDUCATION
PROGRAM OR ACTIVITY RECEIVING
FEDERAL FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE.
TOTAL MY OF NONDISCRIMINATION
PROTECTIONS APPLY TO STUDENT
RECRUITMENT ADMISSIONS
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS RESEARCH
HOUSING COUNSELING FINANCIAL AND
EMPLOYMENT ASSISTANCE HEALTH
INSURANCE BENEFITS AND HEALTH
SERVICES AG ARE TWENTY THREE
FOCUSES ON TWO MAIN IMPACTS OF
TITLE NINE ON THE LIVES OF GIRLS
AND WOMEN OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PARTICIPATION IN ATHLETICS AND
GREATER PROTECTION AGAINST
SEXUAL HARASSMENT ASSAULT ABUSE
AND CALLED ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES.
THE PROMISE OF TITLE NINE IS
THAT A GUARANTEE GUARANTEE IS
THAT TITLE MY GUARANTEES
EDUCATIONAL EQUITY FOR EVERYONE
REGARDLESS OF SEX GENDER
IDENTITY OR GENDER EXPRESSION
WELL THE LAW HAS INCREASED
OPPORTUNITIES FOR GIRLS AND
WOMEN IN ACADEMIC SPORTS OR
OTHER EDUCATIONAL ACTIVITIES IT
IS NOT YET ACHIEVED ITS FULL.
GOAL OF FULL EQUALITY. H. R.
TWENTY THREE RECOGNIZES THE
STRIDES THAT WE HAVE MADE SINCE
TITLE NINE HAS BECOME LAW AND
URGES US TO CONTINUE OUR FIGHT.
FOR EQUAL OPPORTUNITIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AND I HAVE TO CO SPONSOR THE
BILL TESTIFYING TODAY. THE
HONORABLE TONY THURMOND THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION AND KATHY THAN
AUSTIN ON BEHALF OF AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
AND I THINK THEY'RE BOTH ON THE
PHONE. THANK YOU I DO HAVE AN
INDICATION OF STATE
SUPERINTENDENT. OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION ON THE PHONE AND
KATHY VAN AUSTIN ALSO ON THE
PHONE. SUPERINTENDENT THURMAN
ARE YOU WITH US. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR MORNING YES I'M
HERE THANK YOU GO AHEAD PLEASE.
THANK YOU- A GOOD MORNING
RESEARCH HERE AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M HERE TO SUPPORT
HDR TWENTY THREE. THE RESOLUTION
ON THE FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF
TITLE NINE. I WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ONE OR FOUR BACK
UP FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
BILL THANK YOU DON'T. YOU CAN BE
MEMBERS MAIN CHINESE LESSON CALL
UP FOR YOUR CO AUTHORSHIP. THIS
COMMEMORATES LANDMARK FEDERAL.
ENACTED INTO LAW ON JUNE TWENTY
THIRD NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO. THAT
PROVIDES THAT NO PERSON ON THE
BASIS OF SEX EXCLUDED. IN THE
END ALL BE DISCRIMINATED AGAINST
ORGANIZED BENEFIT N EDUCATION
PROGRAM. OR ACTIVITY THAT
RECEIVES FEDERAL ASSISTANCE. FOR
TITLE NINE APPROXIMATELY 93% OF
ALL HIGH SCHOOL ATHLETES REPORT
THE ONLY 7% OF GIRLS. THAT IS IN
CONTRAST TO TODAY WERE
APPROXIMATELY 57% OF ALL HIGH
SCHOOL ATHLETES BOY YOU CAN 43%
GIRLS IN FIFTY YEARS WITH
EIGHTEEN AT 350% INCREASE IN THE
PARTICIPATION HELLO. BUT ACTIVE
AND THE GIRLS HIGH SCHOOL
ATHLETICS BUT IF THE PATIENT HAS
INCREASED MORE THAN ONE THOUSAND
PERCENT. ITS TITLE NINE WAS
INTRODUCED. THE BENEFITS OF
ATHLETIC PARTICIPATION OF WOMEN
AND GIRLS HAS BEEN PROVEN THAT
WHEN GIRLS ARE INVOLVED IN
SCHOOL SPORTS THEY REPAY
EDUCATIONAL PROFESSIONAL AND
HELP THEM THE- FEMALE STUDENTS
WHO PLAY SPORTS IN HIGH SCHOOL
AND 7% HIGHER ANNUAL WAITED.
THAT THEY ARE NONE AT HERE'S
WHAT FEMALE ATHLETE ARE 50% MORE
LIKELY TO GO COLLEGE. AND YOU
KNOW ATHLETES ARE MORE LIKELY
GRADUATE HIGH SCHOOL AND ATTEND
COLLEGE IN GENERAL. GIVEN THAT
WE ARE MORE TO GRADUATE. OVERALL
HIGHER. AND EARN WAGES IN THEIR
CAREERS. THANK FOUR AT THE
SIGNATURE CAGR ON HEALTH.
INCLUDING SO SKILLS HIRES ESTEEM
. LOWER RATE THE- ALL. AT THIS.
THERE'S CERTAINLY A NEED AND UP
TO. MENTAL HEALTH. AND THAT IS
CERTAINLY A TOP PRIORITY FOR ME
TO DEPART OF THAT YOU. OKAY
TWELVE THIRTY TOM. COVERS
ADDITIONAL- PREGNANT TO
PARENTING STUDENTS COULD THE
SEXUAL. ISSUES SUPPORT OF THE P.
PLUS ENTRANCE STUDENTS. GENDER
SANTA STUDENT EQUAL OP. CORRECT
AND INSTRUCTION. WITHOUT. THE
DEPARTMENT BUT MONITORS HOW
STATE SCHOOL. BUT I DON'T MIND
COMPLY. IF SUPPORT ACTIVITY
POINT AT THE BODY THAT
ASSISTANCE IN BEACH WHAT FOR ALL
SCHOOLS. PETER PRIORITY NOTES
SIX THIS COULD. MORE PEOPLE THE
TO A CHEAPER POTENTIAL EQUITABLE
. BETWEEN IN CLOTHING
OPPORTUNITY GAPS ALL STUDENTS
REGARDLESS OF RACE. THE CO. THAT
EXPECTS YEAH THEIR GENDER I.
YEAH EXPRESSION THANK YOU AGAIN
- TO BE OUR AND THE CALL AUTHOR
AT LEAST ASK YOUR I. APR TWENTY
AND- I WILL BE ON THE LINE- WITH
THE SHALL WE WILL BERMAN THIRTY.
SHOULD THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HAPPEN QUESTION THANK
YOU.
OPERATOR DO YOU HAVE KATHY VAN
AUSTIN. I DO NOT SEE HER HAVING-
DIALED IN ON THE HOST LINE OKAY
THANK YOU SO WILL NOW MOVE TO
ANYONE ELSE IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE
TO INDICATE SUPPORT FOR A. J. R.
TWENTY THREE. SEEING NONE WILL
OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR ANYONE
WHO'D LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT
FOR HDR TWENTY THREE. WILL TAKE
NAME. AND AFFILIATION. AND
POSITION ON THE BILL. AND
EDUCATE SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'LL GO
TO LINE THIRTY THREE. PARDON ME
WILL GO TO LINE. TWENTY FIVE.
BUT ME WE WILL GO OUT LINE
THIRTY THREE GO AHEAD PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
LED THE SANCHEZ ON BEHALF OF MR
WARRIORS IN YOUNG WOMEN'S
FREEDOM CENTER AND STRONG
SUPPORT. WE DO HAVE ANOTHER LINE
IN Q. THAT WILL BE LINE TWENTY
GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN FOR THE COMMITTEE KATHY
LYNCH REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
HEALTH PHYSICAL EDUCATION
RECREATION AND DANCE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK TWENTY
FIVE GO AHEAD PLEASE. THE
MORNING MICHELLE MCKAY UNDERWOOD
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
INTERSCHOLASTIC FEDERATION WHICH
GOVERNS HI OPERATIC IN SUPPORT.
NINE THIRTY FOUR. GOOD MORNING
CHRIS TO COME ON THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIPS AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IN SUPPORT. WE HAVE NO
FOR THE LINES INTO AT THIS TIME
MISTER SURE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU OPERATOR SO WILL NOW
MOVE TO OPPOSITION IS THERE
ANYONE. IN THE HEARING
.
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN LINES
FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AJ ARE
TWENTY THREE. DO WE LOSE THE
OPERATOR.
MMHM. WE'RE BACK NOW. LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF A J. R.
TWENTY THREE.
GERMAN THIS IS A TWENTY POINT OF
CLARIFICATION ARE YOU ASKING FOR
THE ROOM RIGHT NOW OVER THE
TELEPHONE LINES NO LUCK SO FUNNY
FROM MOMENT I'M I'M ASKING TO
OPEN BY THE TELEPHONE LINES FOR
OPPOSITION TO AJ ARE TWENTY
THREE. THANK YOU SIR IF YOU WERE
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO IN IN Q. YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU OPERATOR. ALL
RIGHT OF BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. REDRESS THANK YOU I DO WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD ONE OF THE COMMENTS
FROM THE- AMERICAN ASSOCIATION
OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN THAT THEY
HAD PRESENTED. WAS AT THE GAPS
REMAIN FOR WOMEN OF COLOR. ADD
TO RECOGNIZING FIFTIETH
ANNIVERSARY IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT ONE OF THE EXAMPLES
THEY GAVE IS THAT THE PIPELINE
FOR STUDENTS OF COLOR RECEIVING
DOCTORAL DEGREES IS
DISPROPORTIONATELY LOW. ONLY
FIVE POINT 4% OF DOCTORATES ARE
AWARDED TO BLACK STUDENTS AND
MORE THAN A DOZEN FEELS DIDN'T
HAVE A SINGLE BLACK DOCTORAL
RECIPIENT. IT'S TRUE FOR OTHER
PROFESSIONS AND LIGHT I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
RECOGNITION. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE KNOW SOMETHING
GOOD HAS HAPPENED. BUT WE'VE GOT
A WAYS TO GO JUST AS YOU
MENTIONED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THE COMMENTS QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE THIS
BOERNER HORVATH YOU MAY CLOSE
YES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU WE DON'T HAVE
A QUORUM YET BUT ONCE WE
ESTABLISH A QUORUM WILL BE ABLE
TO TAKE IT UP. THANK YOU. WILL
MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER TWO AB
SIXTEEN SIXTY SIX MS BURKE AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MORNING THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I WANT TO
FIRST THANK THE CHAIR THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
INCREDIBLE WORK WITH US ON THIS
BILL TO MAKE SURE THAT WAS
CONSTITUTIONAL AND EFFECTIVE I'M
ACCEPTING THE CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
AND BALLOT ENTITIES ITS
PROTECTION. I WANT TO START BY
SAYING. THAT OUR CONSTITUTION IS
CLEAR HERE IN CALIFORNIA. THAT
WE ARE A STATE THE BRITAX A
WOMAN'S RIGHT TO ACCESS ABORTION
. STATES ACROSS THIS COUNTRY ARE
WORKING TO TAKE THAT RIGHT AWAY
FROM WOMEN BUT WE AS A STATE ARE
CLEAR AND MUST REMAIN VIGILANT
IN ENSURING THAT EVERYBODY IN
OUR BORDERS IS PROTECTED IN
THEIR RIGHT TO ACCESS AN
ABORTION. THE QUESTION IS NOT
WHETHER ABORTIONS WILL HAPPEN AS
WE KNOW WHEN WE'VE SEEN THE DATA
HAS RECENTLY SHOWN. THEY WILL
HAPPEN. THE QUESTION IS WHETHER
WE RISK AND RUIN THE LIVES. OR
WHETHER WE PROTECT THEM. WHETHER
ABORTION WILL BE SAFE. OR
DANGEROUS WHETHER CHOICE WILL BE
LEGAL OR FINANCIALLY RUINOUS.
WITH ABORTION LEFT UP TO THE
STATE IS UP TO A STATE LIKE
CALIFORNIA AND OUR PARTNERS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY WHO SUPPORT A
WOMAN'S RIGHT TO CHOOSE TO STAND
UP FOR THAT RIGHT. I'M PROUD TO
BE HERE TODAY TO PRESENT AB
SIXTEEN SIXTY SIX A MEASURE THAT
WILL PRO ACTIVELY PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS FROM CIVIL
LIABILITY FOR THEIR ACTIONS TO
RECEIVE PROVIDE OR EIGHT AN
ABORTION CARE. AB SIXTEEN SIXTY
SIX A SYMBOL. IT DECLARES THAT
ANY CIVIL ACTION FOR EATING IN
OR RECEIVING AN ABORTION. IS
CONTRARY TO THE PUBLIC POLICY OF
CALIFORNIA AND IS THEREFORE
UNENFORCEABLE IN OUR STATE
COURTS. THE PUBLIC POLICY
EXEMPTION OF THE FULL FAITH AND
CREDIT CLAUSE STATES. THAT THE
STATES ARE NOT REQUIRED TO APPLY
IN OTHER STATES LAW THAT
VIOLATES ITS OWN LEGITIMATE
PUBLIC POLICY AS I'VE SAID THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION IS CLEAR
THAT THE RIGHT TO AN ABORTION IS
PART OF THE PUBLIC POLICY
INTEREST OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THAT'S WE HAVE NO
OBLIGATION TO ENFORCE CIVIL
PENALTIES THAT VIOLATE ABORTION
RIGHTS PROTECTED IN OUR
CONSTITUTION. WHEN A PREGNANT
PERSON'S CHOICES ABOUT THEIR OWN
BODIES QUESTIONED THE LIVES OF
ALL PREGNANT PEOPLE ARE AT
STAKE. WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
HERE IN CALIFORNIA TO PROTECT
WOMEN AND PROVIDERS THAT ARE
ENSURING ACCESS TO COMPREHENSIVE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE. THIS
WILL PROVIDE THOSE PROTECTIONS
AND CONTINUE TO MAKE CALIFORNIA
A SANCTUARY FOR THOSE WHO SEEK
REPRODUCTIVE CHOICE. WITH ME
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL OUR
SELENA SANDOVAL IN OBGYN
PROVIDER UC SAN DIEGO AND DIEGO
ZAMBRANO A PROFESSOR OF LAW AT
STANFORD UNIVERSITY. THANK YOU I
DO HAVE THOSE TWO WITNESSES
LISTED BOTH WITH US ON THE
TELEPHONE SALINAS AND OF ALL ARE
YOU WITH US. YES I'M HERE GO
AHEAD PLEASE. THANKS THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THIS
<c.green>OMMITTEE FOR ALLOWING ME TO</c>
PRESENT TESTIMONY TODAY AGAIN MY
NAME IS DR SPLAINE AT THE END OF
ALL ON THE BOARD CERTIFIED OBGYN
A FAMILY PLANNING SPECIALIST AND
A MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
FUTURE OF ABORTION CAL. I'M HERE
TODAY REPRESENTING DISTRICT NINE
OF THE AMERICAN CONGRESS OF THE
APPLICATIONS AND DATA COLLEGES.
WHO CO SPONSORING ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTEEN SIXTY SIX. AS STATED
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN SIXTY SIX
PROVIDES PROTECTION TO ABORTION
PATIENT AND CLINICIAN. BY
PROHIBITING CIVIL ACTION FROM
ANY OTHER STATE LAW CAN BE
APPLIED TO THOSE IN CALIFORNIA.
AS A PHYSICIAN WHO PROVIDES FULL
SPECTRUM ABORTION CARE I CAN SAY
WITH CERTAINTY THAT THE
PROTECTIONS ARE NOT MOST
IMPORTANT. AS YOU ALL KNOW THE
CURRENT POLITICAL CLIMATE IS
ALLOWING FOR UNPRECEDENTED.
UNPRECEDENTED AMOUNTS OF
LEGISLATION ATTACKING THE
PRODUCTIVE RIGHT. IN CALIFORNIA
MY COLLEAGUES AND I ARE ARE YOU
SEEN PATIENTS TRAVELING FROM
TEXAS UNDER SB EIGHT SAID TAKE
CARE. OKLAHOMA PASSED SIMILAR
LEGISLATION AND WE'RE CONFIDENT
THE TREND WILL CONTINUE. AN
ESTIMATED THIRTY SIX MILLION
PEOPLE WHO CAN GET PREGNANT WILL
LOSE ACCESS TO ABORTION IF THE
SUPREME COURT OVERTURNS ROE V.
WADE. I HAVE BEEN PER ON THE
EFFECT OF LIMITING ACCESS TO
ABORTION. PATIENTS ARE FORCED TO
THE LEADER CARE THERE TRAVELING
HUNDREDS IF NOT THOUSANDS FILED.
REACHING EIGHTEEN MASSIVE
FINANCIAL DIFFICULTIES JUST
UNDERGO A SIMPLE INTAKE MEDICAL
PROCEDURE. AND UNFORTUNATELY THE
PATIENT OF THE LUCKY ONES THE
ONES WITH THE PRIVILEGE AND THE
MEANS TO ACTUALLY TRAVEL OUT OF.
STATE CRAP EVEN MORE CONCERN IS
THE REASON LEGISLATORS
LEGISLATION PRESENTED IN THE
VERY. THAT'S SUPPORT CIVIL SUITS
AGAINST ANYONE PERFORMING AN
ABORTION ON THE VERY RIGHT. I
THINK MY PATIENTS THAT DEVALUE
THEY COME TO ME WITH THE NEED
FOR A SERVICE I CAN PROVIDE AND
I WILL NEVER INTERROGATE I TEACH
US ABOUT THEIR STATE OF ORIGIN.
I KNOW MY COLLEAGUES TREAT THEIR
PATIENTS WITH THE SAME RESPECT
UNFORTUNATELY THIS IS NO LONGER
THEORETICAL AND LEGISLATION LIKE
THIS WITH A CALIFORNIA PROVIDERS
AT RISK. WE KNOW ABORTION IS A
MENTAL HEALTH CARE IN CALIFORNIA
BECOMING A FIFTY THAN IN
DESTINATION BAKER PROTECTING
REPRODUCTIVE RIGHT. I'M HONORED
TO SERVE MY PATIENTS BUT I CAN
ONLY CONTINUE TO DO THAT SAFELY
WITH THE CORPORATE PROTECTION.
PLEASE ALLOW MY COLLEAGUES AND I
THE PEACE OF MIND TO FOCUS ON
THE PATIENT SITTING IN FRONT OF
US EVERY DAY. HELPS PROTECT
ABORTION ACCESS IN CALIFORNIA BY
PUTTING IT ON US AND WE BUILT
SIXTY SIXTY SIX. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND THEY WE HAVE TO.
SEVERAL YES GOOD MORNING TEARS
DOWN MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING ON.
SB SIXTY THREE CORRECT I'M GONNA
PROFESSOR OF LAW AT STANFORD LAW
SCHOOL I WRITE AND TEACH IN THE
FIELD OF CIVIL PROCEDURE IN THE
PAST YEAR I'VE BEEN STUDYING
FACT THAT SB EIGHT ANTI ABORTION
BILL I'M HERE TODAY TO COMMENT
ON POTENTIAL FEDERAL
CONSTITUTIONAL. CHALLENGE THANK
YOU B. B. SIX. I BELIEVE THE
BILL COMPLIES WITH THE FEDERAL
CONSTITUTION AND WOULD SURVIVE A
CONSTITUTIONAL CHALLENGE. THE
BILL REPORT DISCUSS WITH THEM
THE POTENTIAL ISSUE IF THE FULL
FAITH AND CREDIT CLAUSE OF
ARTICLE FOUR SECTION ONE OF THE
UNITED STATES CONSTITUTION.
UNDER THAT CAUGHT THE TO WRITE
REQUIRED TO RECOGNIZE OTHER
STATES STATUTE PUBLIC RECORDS
AND COURT DECISIONS. AND AT
FIRST GLANCE IT WOULD SEEM TO
FORECLOSE THE POSSIBILITY THAT
CALIFORNIA COULD DECLINE TO
ENTERTAIN KIDS UNDER OTHER
STATES BOX. HOWEVER THE FULL
FAITH AND CREDIT CLAUSE DOES NOT
AYE AND QUIET AND CONTAINED
THROUGH WELL RECOGNIZED
EXCEPTION. THE PUBLIC POLICY
EXCEPTION IN THE PENAL JUDGMENTS
EXCEPTION. AND I THINK THE COURT
WOULD UPHOLD AB FIFTEEN EXPECT
UNDER THE WELL RECOGNIZED
EXCEPTIONS. FOR THANK YOU SIX
SIX THE ONE PROHIBITS CALIFORNIA
COURTS FROM ENTERTAINING CLAIMS
UNDER ANTI ABORTION LAWS LIKE
TEXAS SB EIGHT. THAT PROVISION
IS MOST LIKELY CONSTITUTIONAL
UNDER THE PUBLIC POLICY.
EXCEPTION WHICH SPEEDS THAT.
PETER NOT OBLIGATE TO OF AND
OTHER STATE LAWS. AND THE OF THE
LAW RIGHT TO CHOOSE WHETHER TO
PREGNANCIES THIS. WITHIN CAL OWN
JEREMY PUBLIC POLICY. AND THANK
CALIFORNIA MAY WILL TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE PIANO JUDGE
EXCEPT. LEVEL FAITH AND CREDIT
CARD. PREVENTED COURTS FROM SB
SPELL JUDGMENT. INVESTIGATED
CALIFORNIA IS NOT BOUND TO
REPORT ANYCLAIMS UNDER SB EIGHT
OR OTHER COMPATIBLE LOS.
TOONTOWN MY BELIEVE THE LAW
WOULD SURVIVE FEDERAL
CONSTITUTIONAL CHALLENGES. AND
THEREFORE SUPPORT AB. FIFTEEN
SIX SIX. I THANK YOU. WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO OTHERS WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
SIXTEEN SIXTY SIX IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM. HE'S
COME FORWARD TO THE MICROPHONE.
THE MORNING LONG ROADS AND
CURRENT HEAD OF CALIFORNIA WE
ARE PROUD POSTPONED FAIR IN
THIRD THANKS SORRY THANK YOU.
HEARING ROOM. I WILL NOT GO TO
THE PHONE LINES OPERATOR WOULD
YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE
SUPPORT FOR A BI SIXTEEN SIXTY
SIX WE'LL TAKE NAME. AFFILIATION
AND POSITION ON THE BILL. TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'LL GO
TO LINE THIRTY ONE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS JOHN OF THAT GO
WITH THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER CALLING STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB SIXTEEN SIXTY SIX THANK
YOU. BY NINETEEN. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN OR THE COMMITTEE
CINCINNATI NOT LIKE HAVE PUBLIC
AFFAIR CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NURSE MIDWIVES
ASSOCIATION A MEMBER OF THAT
PARTICULAR PORTION COUNCIL AS
WELL AS NAY AROUND PRO CHOICE
CALIFORNIA STEERING COMMITTEE
MEMBER OF THE FUTURE OF ABORTION
CAMP ON STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
TO THE OTHER FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. LINE. TWENTY SIX. YES
GOOD MORNING CHAIR CAN MEMBERS
WHO SINGS A TRACY ROSENBERG
CALLING FROM OAKLAND PRIVACY IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN SIXTY SIX
THANKS. WE HAVE NO FOR THE LINES
INTO AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
BEFORE WE MOVED OPPOSITION WE DO
HAVE A QUORUM SO I WOULD LIKE TO
ESTABLISH THE COURT IF YOU CALL
THE MEMBERS PLEASE STONE HERE.
CUNNINGHAM DAVIES HOLDEN KALRA.
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN REYES. RIVAS
WICKS. THANK YOU AND I WOULD
LIKE TO WELCOME SOME NEW MEMBERS
WITH US BUT HE WORKS IS NOT HERE
RIGHT NOW IS WITH US TEMPORARILY
MISTER REVERSES JOINING US ON A
PERMANENT BASIS WERE VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THAT AND VERY
EXCITED TO HAVE VICE CHAIR
JORDAN CUNNINGHAM BACK. HAPPY TO
HAVE YOU HERE THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US. PERFECT
RIGHT WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
OPPOSITION TO AB SIXTEEN SIXTY
SIX I HAVE TO OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. LISTED BOTH ON THE
TELEPHONE. SUSAN ARE NOW OF THE
RIGHT TO LIFE WEEK AND DEAN
BROYLES OF THE NATIONAL CENTER
FOR LAW AND POLICY. SUSAN ARE
NOW ARE YOU WITH US. I AM GO
AHEAD GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS SUSAN ARNOLD I AM AN
ATTORNEY AND I AM THE DIRECTOR
OF OUTREACH AT THE RIGHT TO LIFE
LEAD AMERICA'S FIRST PRO LIFE
ORGANIZATION WE OPPOSE AB ONE
SIX SIX SIX THE BILL BLATANTLY
VIOLATE THE FULL FAITH AND
CREDIT CLAUSE OF THE U. S.
CONSTITUTION ARTICLE FOUR
SECTION ONE OF THE CONSTITUTION
STATE QUOTE FULL FAITH AND
CREDIT SHALL BE GIVEN IN EACH
STATE TO THE PUBLIC ACTS RECORDS
AND JUDICIAL PROCEEDINGS OF
EVERY. OTHER STATE. IN COURT HAS
APPLIED THE FULL FAITH AND
CREDIT CLAUSE TWO JUDGMENTS AS
RECENTLY AS NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT IN BAKER VERSUS GMC
EXPLICITLY STATING QUOTE THIS
COURT. HAS HELD THAT CREDIT MUST
BE GIVEN TO THE JUDGMENT OF
ANOTHER STATE ALTHOUGH THE FORM
WOULD NOT BE REQUIRED TO
ENTERTAIN THE SUIT ON WHICH THE
JUDGMENT WAS FOUNDED. WHAT DOES
THAT MEAN THAT MEANS YOU CAN'T
IGNORE OTHER STATE LAWS EVEN IF
YOU DON'T LIKE THEM YOU MUST
RESPECT THEM. A. B. ONE SIX SIX
SIX DOES THE OPPOSITE IT
DISRESPECTS OTHER STATE LAWS
THAT DON'T FIT THE RADICAL
ABORTION AGENDA ALLOWING PEOPLE
CONVICTED OF AN ILLEGAL ABORTION
IN ANOTHER STATE TO ESCAPE JEFF
THIS. HEAT IS VIRTUE SIGNALLING
DRESSED UP IN A BILL. WHAT IF
TEXAS DECIDED TO IGNORE
CALIFORNIA'S RECOGNITION OF SAME
SEX MARRIAGES. MAKE IT CLEAR
CALIFORNIA'S SAME SEX MARRIAGES
UNENFORCEABLE NO IT CANNOT. AND
AB ONE SIX SIX SIX CANNOT PICK
AND CHOOSE WHICH STATE JUDGMENT
TO ENFORCE EITHER. AND CONSIDER
THE PRACTICAL EFFECT OF THIS ILL
CONCEIVED BILL BUT THE USERS IN
OTHER STATES COULD TRAFFIC WOMEN
AND CHILDREN AND MINORS. WORSE
THEM TO GET ABORTIONS TO COVER
EVIDENCE AND THEN THE FLEET TO
CALIFORNIA TO AVOID CIVIL
JUDGMENT. HOW DOES THAT PROTECT
WOMEN IT DOES NOT. FOR THESE
REASONS WE URGE YOU TO VOTE NO.
ON AB ONE SIX SIX SIX. THANK YOU
. AND THEN DEEMED BROYLES. YES
YOUR HONOR ROLL CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AS I EXPLAINED
IN MY SUBMITTED LEGAL OPINION
LETTER AND TESTIFYING TO THE
CONSTITUTIONAL ATTORNEY THE
LITIGATOR EXPERIENCE WITH
MEDICAL MALPRACTICE LAWSUITS I
URGE YOU TO VOTE NO ON AB ONE
SIX SIX SIX BECAUSE IT IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND WILL HARM
WOMEN. FIRST THE BILL IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL ARE BASED
CALIFORNIA IS PART OF THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA IS BOUND BY
THE U. S. CONSTITUTION IS NOT A
NATION OF A LAW INTO ITSELF AS
SUCH IT IS OBLIGATED TO
DEMONSTRATE RESPECT FOR THE
PUBLIC LAW THE STATE COURT
JUDGMENTS ABOUT THEIR STATE
JURISDICTION. THIS BILL VIOLATES
ARTICLE FOUR SECTION ONE OF THE
US CONSTITUTION AND TO FADE AWAY
. CALIFORNIA SIX STORE THE JUDGE
IN THE OF OTHER STATE. SECOND
CALIFORNIA DOCTOR BRAZENLY
UNCONSTITUTIONAL POLICY OF
HOSTILITY TOWARD THE LAWS OF
OTHER STATES BOTH ARE FACIAL
VIOLATIONS OF THE FULL FAITH AND
CREDIT CLAUSE IF ENACTED. BY THE
CONSTITUTIONAL ATTORNEY I CAN
ASSURE YOU CALIFORNIA WILL SPEND
A LOT OF MONEY DEPENDING THIS
BILL AND WILL LEAD TO THAT THE
U. S. SUPREME COURT. PLEASE DO
NOT WASTE OUR TAXPAYER MONEY ON
DEFENDING THE INDEFENSIBLE
SECOND THIS BILL WILL HARM
WOMEN. WITH OVER BROAD LAW DOES
NOT NEARLY IMPACT THE FETAL
HEARTBEAT LAWS OF OTHER STATES
RATHER IT'S SWEEPING LANGUAGE
ATTEMPTS TO CREATED AN
IMPENETRABLE SHIELD FOR THE
ASSETS OF CALIFORNIA DOCTORS AND
OTHER HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS. EVEN
IF THEY HAVE BEEN ONE OTHER
STATES COURTS HAVE COMMITTED
MEDICAL MALPRACTICE EVEN IF
OTHER WOMEN OR GIRLS HAVE BEEN
HARMED OR KILLED IN OTHER STATES
BECAUSE THE MEDICAL NEGLIGENCE
OR RECKLESSNESS. IT IS
FUNDAMENTALLY UNJUST TO DENY
PEOPLE BEEN HARMED IN MEDICAL
NEGLIGENCE ELSEWHERE THE RIGHT
TO PURSUE CIVIL DAMAGES IN
CALIFORNIA IT ALSO PROVIDES
ADJUSTABLE LIABILITY PROTECTION
FOR OTHER BAD ACTORS INCLUDING
SEX TRAFFICKERS. UNLAWFULLY.
COERCED WOMEN AND GIRLS. WORKS
INJURED PERSON TO NOT BE DENIED
BAIL LEGAL REMEDIES. INCLUDING
CIVIL. THIS BILL IS SIMPLY AND
ADJUST I STRONGLY URGES
COMMITTEE TO VOTE NO BECAUSE IT
YES EIGHTY SIX ONE SIX SIX SIX
WILL HARM WOMEN. UNITS FACIALLY
UNCONSTITUTIONAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. RIGHT WILL NOW MOVE
TO THEM TO THE PUBLIC IN THE
HEARING ROOM WHO'D LIKE TO
INDICATE OPPOSITION TO AB
SIXTEEN SIXTY SIX IF YOU COME
FORWARD WILL NOT TAKE ANY
FURTHER TESTIMONY BUT WILL TAKE
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON
THE BILL THANK YOU FOR A GREAT
BURKE FOR THE CALIFORNIA FAMILY
COUNCIL IN STRONG OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
IN THE HEARING ROOM. ALL RIGHT
THING NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR. ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE
OPPOSITION TO AB SIXTEEN SIXTY
SIX. EXPECT OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
. WE'LL GO TO LINE FORTY SIX.
WHERE SHALL CONNOR LEGISLATIVE
LIAISON FOR CONCERNED WOMEN FOR
AMERICA WE STRONGLY OPPOSED AB
SIXTEEN SIXTY SIX. WE HAVE ONE
MORE LINE QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT
WHILE WE PROVIDE THEM THE LINE
NUMBER. GO TO LINE FORTY GO
AHEAD PLEASE. YES TIS IS TO
RESET BRANDON AN ATTORNEY AND
PRESIDENT OF THE RIGHT TO LIFE
CREEK IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE TO DO T THIS
TIME. THANK YOU OPERATOR YOU MAY
CLOSE THE LINES AND I'LL BRING
IT BACK TO THE- COMMITTEE. FIRST
I WOULD LIKE TO SAY I DO
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S
CONSTITUTIONAL TENSION HERE AND
I THINK THE ANALYSIS DOES AN
EXCELLENT JOB OF. LAYING THAT
OUT AND- I DO APPRECIATE THE
FACT OF. THE QUESTION OF US
RESPECTING EVEN THOUGH. SOME OF
THE LAWS THAT ARE BEING
PROMULGATED OTHER STATES I DON'T
THINK WE HEAR NECESSARILY HAVE
RESPECT FOR THEM BUT- THIS IS
ABOUT RESPECT FOR OUR LAWS OUR
CONSTITUTION THAT'S THE BALANCE
HERE AND THAT'S WHAT I THINK
MAKES THIS. APPROPRIATELY
CONSTITUTIONAL AND I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE EXCELLENT
ANALYSIS RIGHT MISTER KALRA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF ALSO
I. REALLY APPRECIATE THE NOW
SAYS AND IF IT IS A VERY CLEAR
PUBLIC POLICY. EXEMPTION TO YOUR
APPOINTMENTS OR SHARE THAT- YOU
KNOW WE HAVE OUR OBLIGATION TO
OUR RESIDENTS OUR COMMUNITY ARE
WOMEN- AND WE'RE NOT GONNA ALLOW
OTHER STATES TO DICTATE- HOW WE
SEE FIT IN. PROTECTING OUR
COMMUNITY AND THE PEOPLE LIVE IN
OUR STATE AND- AND DOES THAT
WOULD BE UNDER OUR JURISDICTION
AND SO- I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
I KNOW IT'S A- CAN BE VERY
CONTENTIOUS TO BRING- FOR BILLS
IN THIS ARENA. BUT IT'S SO
IMPORTANT AND SO VERY IMPORTANT
AND I'M VERY GRATEFUL- THAT WE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO STEM THE
TO MAKE IT VERY CLEAR- WHERE
WHERE WE STAND UP NOT ONLY AS A
STATE BUT WHERE OUR VALUES AE-
IN TERMS OF. PROTECTING A
WOMAN'S RIGHT TO CHOOSE- AND OF
WOMEN'S- SAKSHAM NATION- OVER
THEIR LIVES IN THEIR BODIES. AND
AS EVERY MOTIONS SURE OTHERS NOT
LIKE TO MAKE A MOTION. SO WE DO
HAVE A MOTION AS THEIR SECOND.
AND A SECOND THANK YOU. REDRESS
PROTEGER. OKAY THANK YOU ANY
OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. ALL RIGHT
CIGNA YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FOR HIS COMMENTS I
ALSO WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR THE EXCELLENT ANALYSIS AND-
I THINK IT DOESN'T INCREDIBLE
JOB OF LAYING OUT EXACTLY WHAT.
WE BELIEVE TO BE THE CASE HERE
WHICH IS THAT ALTHOUGH THE FULL
FAITH AND CREDIT CLAUSE IS
ABSOLUTELY PART OF THE
CONSTITUTION AND ONE THAT OUR
STATE ENFORCES EVERY SINGLE DAY
THAT THERE ARE EXCEPTIONS AND IT
THIS CLEARLY FALLS UNDER THAT
EXCEPTION. AS MISTER DIMARTINO
SAID AND THEN ALICE'S REITERATES
BOTH BECAUSE THESE LAWS ARE
PENAL IN NATURE THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE BRINGING THESE SUITS DO NOT
UNDER CALIFORNIA'S LAWS HAVE
STANDING THEY HAVEN'T BEEN
INJURED. I'M IN ADDITION TO THAT
WE HAVE A CLEAR PUBLIC POLICY
EXEMPTION AND WE HAVE NO
LAWCENTER BOX THAT WOULD DO THIS
IN OUR OWN STATE BETTER K. STATE
COURT WOULD ENFORCE AND SO AS A
RESULT WE DO NOT NEED TO ENFORCE
THOSE IN OTHER STATES. I WOULD
LIKE TO CORRECT THE RECORD ON
ONE THING THAT WAS SAID BY THE
OPPOSITION AS A LONGTIME ALLY OF
THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY I WANT TO BE
CLEAR THAT WHEN SOME STATES DID
ALLOW FOR GAY MARRIAGE. THOSE
WHO WERE MARRIED IN THE STATE'S
WERE NOT GIVEN THE BENEFITS OF
THOSE MARRIAGES AND OTHER STATES
AND I DON'T WANT THE RECORD OF
HISTORY TO BE UNCLEAR ON THAT
BECAUSE THAT WAS WHAT HAPPENED
AS THE SISTER OF SOMEONE WHO IS
MARRIED HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND
WAS NOT GRANTED THOSE PRIVILEGES
IN WISCONSIN. I WANT THAT TO BE
CLEAR- I ALSO WANT TO BE CLEAR
THAT THAT LANGUAGE AS WE WORKED
ON WITH- THE COMMITTEE WAS
CRAFTED TO ENSURE THE
MALPRACTICE SUITS WHERE SOMEONE.
IS INJURED BECAUSE THE DOCTOR
DOES NOT DO THEIR JOB AS THEY
SHOULD. DOES NOT FALL UNDER THIS
LAW AS YOU WILL READ THAT
LANGUAGE OF THE LIGHT IS. NARROW
IN SCOPE TO JUST THOSE THAT ARE
ASSISTING IN. OR GIVING SOMEONE
AN ABORTION NOT SOMEONE WHO DOES
SO WHILE COMMITTING MALPRACTICE.
I'M AND WITH THAT I JUST WANT TO
CLOSE BY SAYING THAT. I AM SO
GRATEFUL TO BE CALIFORNIAN AS A
WOMAN AS A MOTHER OF A YOUNG
DAUGHTER. I LIVE IN A STATE THAT
WILL FOREVER GIVE MY DAUGHTER I
HOPE NOT THOUGH I SHOULDN'T SAY
FOREVER. THE RIGHT TO CONTROL
HER OWN FUTURE AND HER OWN BODY
AND TODAY WE HAVE THE RIGHT TO
ENSURE THAT NO MATTER WHAT
HAPPENS IN ANY OTHER STATE IN
THIS UNION. THAT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO GRANT THOSE RIGHTS
TO THE WOMEN AND GIRLS THE STATE
AND WE WILL SAY TO EVERY SINGLE
PROVIDER IN OUR BORDERS WE'VE
GOT YOUR BACK BECAUSE WE BELIEVE
WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS PROVIDING.
HEALTH CARE. TO PEOPLE WHO NEED
IT. AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK PRIVATE. THANK YOU WE DO
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND THAT
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
HEALTH CALDERON PLEASE STONE AYE
STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM. DAVIES
HOLDEN KALRA. KALRA AYE KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN. MAIENSCHEIN AYE
REYES. REYES AYE RIVAS RIVERSIDE
WICKS. WE PUT THE BILL CALL IT
NEEDS ONE MORE VOTE. ALL RIGHTS
- CALL UP NOW MISS BONTA ITEM
NUMBER THREE A. B. EIGHTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN AND AS SHE COMES
FORWARD I'LL TAKE A MOTION ON
THE CONSENT AGENDA. OKAY THANK
YOU. CONSENT AGENDA CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE STONE AYE STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I DAVIES
HOLDEN KALRA. KALRA KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN MENTIONED I REYES
REYES AYE RIVAS RIVERSIDE WICKS. THANK YOU THE CONSENT AGENDA
IS OUT THAT IS AB SIXTEEN SIXTY
ONE DAVIES A. B. SEVENTEEN
SIXTEEN MAIENSCHEIN AB SEVENTEEN
TWENTY SIX AG WE ARE CURRY AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY DAVIES AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY FIVE WHEN AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY FIVE BENEFITS AND
AB SIXTEEN SIXTY SIX. CHEN
RIGHT. A. B. EIGHTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN MINS BONTA MORGAN MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE
TO START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS ALSO
CARRIED LIKE TO EXPRESS MY
APPRECIATION TO YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR HELP WITH THESE
AMENDMENTS. IN TWENTY TWENTY IN
RESPONSE TO A GROWING NUMBER OF
EXISTING CALIFORNIA HOMES BEING
ACQUIRED BY INVESTOR
CORPORATIONS THE LEGISLATURE
ENACTED SB TEN SEVENTY NINE
WHICH PROVIDED A SPECIAL WINDOW
FOR RESIDENTS OR NON PROFITS TO
MATCH OR EXCEED THE BID OF
INVESTORS AT FORECLOSURE
AUCTIONS. HOWEVER DESPITE THE
LAW HOUSING ADVOCATES HAVE
OBSERVED FOR PROFIT ACTORS
CONTINUE TO FIND WAYS TO DEFY
AND MANIPULATE CURRENT LAW IN
THEIR FAVOR. FOR EXAMPLE IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE IN AT LEAST
ONE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA CASE ALL
PRESENT BIDDERS AT AN AUCTION
WERE URGED TO SIGN A WAIVER
FORM. ATTESTING THAT THEY WERE
PERSPECTIVE OWNER OCCUPANTS AND
WOULD USE THE PROPERTY AS THEIR
PRIMARY RESIDENCE EVEN WHEN
CERTAIN BIDDERS HAD NO INTENTION
OF DOING SO. THESE ACTIONS
EFFECTIVELY PRECLUDED THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR ACTUAL
PROSPECTIVE HOMEOWNERS TO PLACE
A BID ON THESE HOMES IN OTHER
CASES ILLEGITIMATE NONPROFITS
PURCHASE THESE HOMES WITH NO
INTENTION OF PROVIDING HOUSES
HOUSING FOR FAMILIES ONE SUCH
ILLEGITIMATE NONPROFIT SLIPPED A
HOME AT A 12% PROFIT. AFTER ONLY
OWNING IT FOR A FEW SHORT WEEKS
AND WITHOUT MAKING ANY
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE PROPERTY TO
JUSTIFY THE PRICE INCREASE. MY
BILL EIGHTEEN EIGHT EIGHTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN THE HOUSING THE
HOMES IN COMMUNITY HANDS ACT WAS
RESOLVED IMPLEMENTATION GAPS IN
THE EXISTING FORECLOSURE
INTERVENTION ON INSURING FOR
CLOSED HOMES BE PRIORITIZED FOR
RESIDENTS AND THE COMMUNITY NOT
CORPORATIONS. SPECIFICALLY AB
EIGHTEEN THIRTY SEVEN ROBOT
REVISES THE DEFINITION OF AN
ELIGIBLE NONPROFIT BUYER EXPANDS
AFFIDAVIT AND DECLARATION.
REQUIREMENTS FOR ELIGIBLE
BIDDERS STRENGTHENS ENFORCEMENT
AND REQUIRES THAT IN SPECIFIC
CASES UNITS BE MAINTAINED AS
AFFORDABLE TO LOWER IN COME. ALL
AS EIGHTEEN AB EIGHTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN AS A FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE
WAY FOR A STATE TO PROMOTE
HOMEOWNERSHIP PRESERVATION. TO
ENSURE PROPER IMPLEMENTATION OF
pINTERVENTION LAW AND HELP KEEP
HOMEOWNERSHIP AND HOUSING WITHIN
THE REACH OF FAMILIES. WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE REALTORS
ASSOCIATION TO ADDRESS THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL AND HAVE
TAKEN SEVERAL OF THE AMENDMENTS
THEY REQUESTED. THERE'S ONE
OUTSTANDING ISSUE THAT WE WERE
NOT ABLE TO AGREE ON AT THE TIME
IN TIME FOR TODAY'S HEARING BUT
WE REMAIN COMMITTED TO REACHING
A CONSENSUS. THANK YOU AND AS
WITNESSES PERMITS FOR IT WITH ME
TODAY I HAVE ANY KINDS OF SHAKE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
LAND TRUST NETWORK A CALL ON
SERVE THIS BILL. AND MIKE BALOCH
WITH THE UNITED TRUSTEES
ASSOCIATION. I THANK YOU AND
BOTH WITNESSES ARE HERE IN THE
ROW SO PLEASE. FIVE THANK YOU SO
MUCH HONORABLE CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MY NAME IS AMY HIGHNESS SHEIKH
WITH WILDCAT CONSULTING
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY LAND TRUST NETWORK
TODAY. THE COMMUNITY LAND TRUST
MODEL IS BASED ON ACQUIRING
PROPERTY AND STEWARDING THE LAND
IN PERPETUAL TRUST FOR LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES WE DO THIS
THROUGH OUR NINETY NINE YEAR
GROUND LEASE WE RETAIN OWNERSHIP
OF THE LAND UNDERNEATH THE
STRUCTURES WE ACQUIRE AND WE
LEASE OR SELL THE STRUCTURES ON
TOP OF THE LAND FOR A PHOTO.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING NATURALLY WE
WERE QUITE EXCITED WHEN SB TEN
SEVENTY NINE THE HOUSING FOR
HOME OWNERS NOT CORPORATIONS ACT
WENT INTO EFFECT JANUARY FIRST
OF LAST YEAR. ONE OF OUR
AFFILIATE CLT IS PARTNERED WITH
TENANTS JOCELYN FOREMAN FROM
PINOLE CALIFORNIA TO ACQUIRE THE
HOME SHE HAD BEEN RENTING AS THE
FIRST TO KNOWN SB TEN SEVENTY
NINE ACQUISITION. WE THOUGHT WE
COULD HELP THOUSANDS OF JOCELYN
FOREMAN'S ACROSS THIS GREAT
STATE WHEN THE FORECLOSURE
INTERVENTION HOUSING
PRESERVATION PROGRAM WAS FUNDED
IN JUNE OF LAST YEAR TO HELP
NONPROFIT PARTNERS. NONPROFITS
PARTNER WITH ASPIRING LOW INCOME
HOMES HOME OWNERS TO ACQUIRE
PROPERTIES THROUGH THE S. B. TEN
SEVENTY NINE PROCESS HOWEVER IN
ATTENDING MORE FORECLOSURE
AUCTION SOME THINGS BECAME CLEAR
EXACTLY WHAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA HAD- US. LINEATED HERE
ABOUT THE OF FRAUDULENT SB TEN
SEVENTY NINE WAIVER FORM AND
ALSO THE FRAUDULENT NON PROFITS
. THESE EXAMPLES OF FRAUDULENT
BEHAVIOR ARE EXACTLY WHY WE
URGENTLY NEED AB EIGHTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN THE HOMES IN COMMUNITY
HANDS ACT WE THANK THE AUTHOR
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA FOR HER
VISIONARY LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE. AND WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB EIGHTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU THAT'S WORTH PLEASE MR
TURN MEMBERS MIKE BILLOWED ON
BEHALF OF THE UNITED TRUSTEES
ASSOCIATION. FORECLOSURE
TRUSTEES ARE REALLY THE TIP OF
THE SPEAR ON THE S. B. TEN
SEVENTY NINE PROCESS AS A MATTER
OF FACT THERE THE ONLY ACTOR
IT'S AND THEY'RE SLOWLY
ADMINISTERING THIS. THIS
PROGRAM. SO IT IS THE
FORECLOSURE TRUSTEE AFTER THE
TRUSTEE'S SALE WHO RECEIVES THE
NOTICES OF INTENT TO BID. WHO
TAKES THE ACTUAL BIDS AND
EVALUATES THEM THE VALUE WAIT
THE BONA FIDES OF THE NONPROFIT
ENTITY AND SO IS THE WHOLE
PROCESS THROUGH TO COMPLETION.
THEY ARE THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
CALLING ME AND TALKING ABOUT
SHADY NON PROFITS THAT APPEARED
TO BE ATTEMPTING TO ABUSE THE
SYSTEM ACTUALLY I'VE ACTUALLY
RECEIVED CALLS MYSELF IN MY
OFFICE. FROM ALLEGED NON PROFITS
THAT SOUNDED SHADY TO ME. SO
THIS BILL IS IMPORTANT. THAT
TRUSTEES ARE ACTUALLY GETTING
SUED ABOUT THESE ISSUES TODAY
AND I'LL JUST GIVE AN EXAMPLE OF
ONE. SO THE TRUSTEE TOOK A BED
FROM A NON PROFIT INVESTIGATED
THE NONPROFIT LOOK AT THEIR
ORGANIZATION DOCUMENTS AND SAW.
THAT AFFORDABLE HOUSING WAS ONE
OF THE PURPOSES IN THE
ORGANIZATION DOCUMENTS OF THE
ORGANIZATION. THEY GOT SUED
BECAUSE THE LAW SAYS THE PRIMARY
PURPOSE OF THE ORGANIZATION MUST
BE AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AND THE
ASSOCIATE AND THE ORGANIZATION
DOCUMENTS IDN'T SAY PRIMERICA
IT JUST SAID IT WAS ONE OF THE
PURPOSES SILK LITIGATION IS
COMING OUT OF THIS PRO. PROGRAM
AND WE THINK THAT THE PROVISIONS
OF THE BILL WILL HELP IMPROVE
THE PROCESS- TO THE BENEFIT OF
THE PUBLIC AND FRANKLY TRUSTEES
AND FOR THAT WE WOULD ASK FOR AN
IPHONE. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT IS
THERE ANYONE HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE
SUPPORT FOR A BI THIRTEEN
EIGHTEEN THIRTY SEVEN. I'D SAY
NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO INDICATE SUPPORT FOR A BI
EIGHTEEN THIRTY SEVEN. I DO
EXPRESSED SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE'LL GO TO LINE FORTY FOUR GO
AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRED MEMBERS ON THAT FROM
MOST WITH THE PUBLIC ADVOCATES
WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTEEN THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU
. NINE FIFTY FOUR. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS LEO GOLDBERG CO DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA KAMALA
INTEREST NETWORK AND WE ARE ALSO
IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIRMAN
WE HAVE NO OTHER LINES INTO IT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU THE BILL
NOW MOVES TO OPPOSITION I DO NOT
HAVE ANY OPPOSITION LISTED BUT
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM WHO'D LIKE TO INDICATE
OPPOSITION OR SPEAKING OF IN
OPPOSITION TO AB EIGHTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN. SEEING NONE OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN. THIS WEEK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE DO
HAVE NE LINE QUEUING UP ONE
MOMENT WHILE THEY PROVIDE THEIR
LINE NUMBER. WE'LL GO TO LINE
TWENTY FOUR GO AHEAD PLEASE. IF
YOU'RE A MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JENNIFER SLACK ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS WE
WANTED TO TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO THANK BOTH YOURSELF AUTHOR
AND SPONSORS FOR THEIR
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH US TO
RESOLVE A MAJORITY OF OUR
CONCERNS WE GIVEN THE
ALTERNATIVE HAVE ONE REMAINING.
CONCERN BUT WE ARE HOPEFUL THAT
WE'LL BE ABLE TO REACH A
RESOLUTION AT A LATER COMMITTEE
AGAIN- CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS ARE EXTRAORDINARILY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE WORK OF THIS
COMMITTEE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE FIFTY NINE FIFTY ONE. HELLO
NINE FIFTY ONE GO AHEAD PLEASE.
HELLO HE DID A VERY YES WE CAN.
OKAY I MY NAME IS MARIE THIRD ON
. AND I AM A SELF ADVOCATE AND I
SUPPORT HIS DECISION MAKING- THE
BILL AB ONE SIX SIX. THREE I'M
SORRY WE'RE NOT ON THAT BILL
JUST YET THAT'LL COME UP A
LITTLE BIT LATER IN THE HEARING
BUT TOLD K. ALL RIGHT. TURNOUT
BILLET DARI IT'LL BE COMING AND
DON'T KNOW EXACTLY THE TIME BUT
IT WILL BE COMING OUT. MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION. AND A SECOND. RIGHT THIS
PARTY OF A CLOSE THANK YOU WHEN
THE LEGISLATURE ENACTED THE
EXISTING FORECLOSURE
INTERVENTION LAW AND TWENTY
TWENTY THE INTENT WAS TO ENSURE
INVESTOR CORPORATIONS WERE NOT
ALLOWED TO CAPITALIZE ON A
FORECLOSURE CRISIS LIKE THE ONE
THAT WE EXPERIENCED IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT WHICH LED TO THE
DISPLACEMENT OF COMMUNITY
MEMBERS INCREASED HOMELESSNESS
AND A MASSIVE LOSS OF BLACK AND
LATINO WEALTH IN OUR COMMUNITIES
AB EIGHTEEN THIRTY SEVEN IS A
NECESSARY STEP TO STRENGTHEN
EXISTING LAW AND ENSURE HOMES
ARE PRIORITIZED FOR OUR FELLOW
COMMUNITY MEMBERS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND THAT MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE AYE STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I. DAVIES
HOLDEN KALRA. KALRA AYE KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
REYES REYES AYE RIVAS. RIVAS AYE
WICKS. THAT BILLS OUT QUICKLY
THANK YOU. WE NOW MOVE TO ITEM
NUMBER FOUR A. B. EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY SIX MISTER BRIAN.
WELCOME. I HAD I WILL WAIT FOR
YOUR WINDOWS TO COME UP. THE
BEST TEAM IN PERSON. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS- TODAY
I RISE TO PRESENT AB SIXTEEN
EIGHTY SIX A BILL THAT WOULD
CLARIFY REFERRAL CRITERIA
CONCERNING DEPENDENT CHILDREN
PLACED IN FOSTER CARE AS WIDE
AGREEMENT. WITHIN THE CHILD
WELFARE COMMUNITY THAT THE BEST
THING FOR MOST CHILDREN IN
FOSTER CARE TO BE REUNIFIED WITH
THEIR FAMILIES. HOWEVER SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR WILL. BEGIN
MAKING STATES RECOUP THE COST OF
FOSTER CARE FROM PARENTS OF
FOSTER YOUTH. A CONTRADICTORY
PRACTICE THAT GOES AGAINST THE
STATED GOAL. OF REUNIFYING
FAMILIES CALIFORNIA DATA SHOWS
THAT MANY PARENTS ARE REQUIRED
TO PAY THESE EXPENSES.
EXPERIENCE EXTREME POVERTY. THE
PRACTICE IS WRONG FOR MANY
REASONS WHEN PARENTS HAVE TO PAY
FOR THEIR CHILD'S DAYCARE
CHILDREN MEANING CARE ALMOST
SEVEN MONTHS LONGER. THAT IS
NECESSARY WE SAY THAT WE SUPPORT
FAMILY REUNIFICATION ARE CURRENT
LAWS MAKE IT HARDER FOR FAMILIES
TO DO JUST THAT. REUNIFY IT ALSO
HAS A DISPROPORTIONATE EFFECT.
ON BLACK BROWN POINT INDIGENOUS
FAMILIES. EVEN MORE SO THAN
OTHERS. WE SAY THE MONEY'S
TAXPAYER DOLLARS WISELY TO
INVEST IN PROGRAMS THAT WORK FOR
FAMILIES BUT THE RESEARCH SHOWS
THE TRYING TO COLLECT PAYMENTS
FROM CPS INVOLVED FAMILIES COST
TAXPAYERS MORE THAN THE
GOVERNMENT COLLECTING PAYMENTS
BACK FOR EVERY ONE DOLLAR IN
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS WE ACTUALLY
COLLECT TWENTY SEVEN CENTS. AB
SIXTEEN EIGHTY SIX REQUIRE FAR
WELL FOR AGENCIES TO PRESUME
THAT PAYMENT A FOSTER CARE
COSTS. UNNECESSARILY EXTEND
CHILDREN'S TIME IN FOSTER CARE.
WHICH IS ACTUALLY THE CASE AND
PRACTICE. AT THE EXPENSE OF
CHILDREN. IS POLICY CLARIFIES
BUT THAT THE CLARIFICATION THIS
POLICY WILL ENSURE THAT THE
DECISION ABOUT REFERRALS ARE
MADE MORE UNIFORM ACROSS ALL
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA WHICH WILL REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF FAMILIES REQUIRED TO
PAY FOR THE CHILD STAY IN FOSTER
CARE BY REDUCING THE NUMBER OF
REFERRALS PARENTS SEEKING TO BE
REUNITED WITH THEIR FAMILIES
WILL BE ABLE TO USE. THAT THAT
INCOME INSTEAD OF PAYING IT BACK
TO THE COUNTIES TO BUILD THEIR
HOMES AND TO BUILD A HEALTHY AND
THRIVING ENVIRONMENT. FOR THEM
AND THEIR CHILDREN. I'M JOINED
TODAY BY. SABRINA FORTE DIRECTOR
OF POLICY AND IMPACT LITIGATION
ON BEHALF OF THE ALLIANCE FOR
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS. AND KATHY
SINGLING MCDONALD EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR. OF ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILD WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION TO TEST. THANK THANK
YOU I DO HAVE THOSE TWO
WITNESSES LISTED SABRINA FOR
TODAY ARE YOU WITH US ON THE
TELEPHONE. YES I'M HERE GO AHEAD
PLEASE WHEN YOU WORK. MORNING
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS THE
BRING OF WORKING ON BEHALF OF
THE CHEC ALLIANCE FOR
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS THE CROWD
COSPONSORED EIGHTY IN EIGHTY SIX. HAS THE OPERATOR WE SEEM TO
HAVE SOME. HEY BEFORE TO GO
AHEAD. ALL RIGHT GOOD MORNING
HERE NUMBER THAT IS THE THING OF
WHY CAN BE HALF OF THE ALLIANCE
FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS THE
PASSCODE ON THIRD EIGHTY SIX
EIGHTY SIX I WANT TO SHARE THE
STORY OF ONE INDIVIDUAL EREKAT
WHO CLAIM TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB SIXTEEN EIGHTY SIX TODAY BUT
WAS UNABLE TO PARTICIPATE AT THE
LAST MINUTE- DAUGHTER WAS PLCED
IN FOSTER CARE IN AUGUST THE
TWENTY NINETEEN. AFTERWARD SHE
CALLED THE COURT TO RESPOND TO
IN ORDER TO PAY FOR THE COST TO
PROVIDERS HERE ORDERED TO TAKE
NINE HUNDRED FORTY FIVE DOLLARS
MONTHLY FEE BUT HARD TO REDUCE
HER AMOUNT TO FOUR HUNDRED
NINETY FIVE DOLLARS A MONTH.
LASTED FOR THE REST OF THE TIME
HER DAUGHTER WAS IN CARE PLUS
ANOTHER FOUR MONTHS AFTERWARDS
ERICA KEEPS PLAN REQUIRED FOR
COMPLETE MULTIPLE THIRD OFFENSE
SHE DID EVERYTHING SHE COULD TO
GET HER CHILD BACK TAKING
PARENTING CLASSES MENTAL HEALTH
EVALUATION AND PARTICIPATING IN
A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE PROGRAM. THE
CARD TO HOLD ON TO HER HOUSING
WITH AN EXTRA. FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS A MONTH. SHE COULDN'T
MAINTAIN HER. THE COUNTY. MANY
TIMES. FOR HER TO SHOW AT THE
PIANO OTHER MEETINGS THAT WE'RE
ALWAYS APPROVED BY KERN. LEADING
TO HER BEING MY GO. ERICA OPEN
AT LEAST REUNIFY WITH HER AND
NEARLY TWO YEAR. BUT ONCE THE
COMMITTEE TO THAT PARA PAY FOR
PROCTER GOES AGAINST CHILD
WELFARE PRESIDENT FOR MAINLY TO
PROTECT AND HELP CHILDREN AND
FAMILY REUNIFY. WE AGREE WITH
ERR AND DEAR I MONEY SIX EIGHT
THAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND
THE CENTRAL HERE IN THE ROOM
THANK YOU MISTER SHE FIRST
CENTER MCDONOUGH WITH THE COUNTY
WHAT DIRECTOR OF SUCH. AS THE
OTHER NOTED THIS BILL CLARIFIES
PAYMENT REFERRAL CRITERIA FOR
PARENTS WHOSE CHILDREN ARE
PLACED IN THE FOSTER CARE. UNDER
CURRENT LAW THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM CAN BUT IT'S NOT REQUIRED
TO MAKE A REFERRAL FOR PAYMENT
M. IF IT IS DETERMINED THAT IT
WOULD NOT BE A BARRIER TO BE
UNIFICATION. THIS LAW WHICH TO
W. D. A. ACTUALLY COSPONSORED A
NUMBER OF YEARS AGO HAS REDUCED
REFERRALS BUT THEY DO STILL
OCCUR ON A CASE BY CASE BASIS.
THIS BILL WOULD CLARIFY THAT SEE
THE BEST MUST PRESUME THAT
PAYMENT OF SUPPORT BY THE PARENT
IS LIKELY TO POSE A BARRIER TO
BE UNIFICATION. AND THIS IS
CONSISTENT WITH RESEARCH FOR
EVERY ONE HUNDRED DOLLARS THE
CHILD WELFARE INVOLVED. PARENTS
PAY THEIR CHILD TO RATIONING
CARE LINCOLN'S FOR SIX POINT SIX
MONTHS AND THIS IS EVEN WORSE
FOR FAMILIES OF COLOR WHO ARE
OVER REPRESENTED IN CHILD
CALIFORNIA'S CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM. FAMILIES WERE SUPPORTED
BY PUBLIC SYSTEMS ARE BETTER
ABLE TO SUCCESSFULLY REUNIFIED
WITH THEIR CHILDREN AND
CONVERSELY ENFORCING PAYMENTS BY
FOSTER BY PARENTS WHO ARE
FINANCIALLY STRUGGLING ALREADY.
GENERALLY JUST SERVES TO MAKE IT
MORE DIFFICULT TO REUNIFY SO
THIS CLARIFICATION EFFECTIVELY
NARROWS THE CIRCUMSTANCES IN
WHICH WILL MAKE REFERRALS. AND
IT WILL IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR
FOSTER YOUTH AND THEIR
BIOLOGICAL FAMILIES BY EATING
FAMILY REUNIFICATION WHILE
KEEPING CALIFORNIA LAW WITHIN
FEDERAL PARAMETERS. THANK YOUNG
WE URGE OUR I THOUGHT. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT OPERATOR WILL NOW
GO TO THE PHONE LINES FOR ANYONE
WHO'D LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT
FOR A BI. SIXTEEN EIGHTY SIX
WILL NOT TAKE ANY FURTHER
TESTIMONY BUT PEOPLE ARE WELCOME
TO GIVE US THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION. AND THEIR POSITION
ON THE BILL. TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO
THIRTY ONE GO AHEAD PLEASE. HI
THIS IS JOHN CAN GO- CALLING
FROM THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER- CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN EIGHTY SIX
THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO FOR THE
LINES INTO AT THIS TIME MISTER
CHAIRMAN. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
OPERATOR WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
OPPOSITION TO AB SIXTEEN EIGHTY
SIX IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM I DON'T HAVE ANY
LISTED. IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WHO'D LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO AB SIXTEEN
EIGHTY SIX. ALL RIGHT SING NINE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANY. WHEN YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB EIGHT SIXTEEN EIGHTY SIX. TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. TWO
GERMAN WE HAVE KNOWING QUEUED UP
AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU. THIS POINT THEN I'LL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS MISTER KALRA
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN- AND
THANK YOU ALSO TO THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD- YOU
REUNIFICATION SHOULD BE AND
ALWAYS SHOULD BE- THE NUMBER ONE
CALL AND VERY CLEARLY AND THE
RESEARCH IS PRETTY ASTOUNDING-
ALTHOUGH I GUESS. YOU KNOW IT
CAN BE PREDICTED BUT STILL- THAT
THOSE NUMBERS ARE PRETTY CLEAR
THAT- WE'RE MAKING IT HARDER-
AND SO I'M VERY HAPPY SUPPORT
THIS BILL WITHOUT BEING. ADDED
ON AS A CO AUTHOR. OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU YOU HAVE A
MOTION IS THEIR SECOND. AND A
SECOND THANK YOU OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE. ALL
RIGHT SEEING NONE THIS RIDE YOU
MAY CLOSE THE RESEARCH IS VERY
CLEAR THAT. THE LIKELIHOOD OF
TOUCHING THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM ONLY DISRUPTS CHILDREN'S
LIVES AND INCREASE THE
LIKELIHOOD THAT YOU TOUCH OTHER
SYSTEMS LIKE THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM- AB SIXTEEN
EIGHTY SIX WILL ENSURE THAT
FAMILY UNIFICATION AS LONG WHAT
NO LONGER DISRUPTED BY
INCREASING FINANCIAL BURDENS.
LEVIED ON FAMILIES HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY FOSKETT STRONGLY ASK
THIS COMMITTEE TO JOIN. JOIN ME
IN MOVING THIS BILL. THANK YOU
WE DO HAVE THE MOST IN A SECOND
THAT MOTIONS TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HUMAN SERVICES.
KALRA STONE AYE STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM NO
DAVIES. HOLDEN HOLDEN I KALRA
KALRA AYE KILEY. KILEY NO
MAIENSCHEIN MENTION I REYES.
RIVAS RIVAS AYE WICKS. THAT
STILL NEED ONE MORE VOTES WILL
PUTON CALL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
FOR RIGHT I REMEMBER FIVE AB
SIXTEEN SIXTY THREE MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN.
OKAY. THANK GOD THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I WANT
TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS AS PROPOSED IN THE
ANALYSIS AND THANKING THE CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE STAFF FOR YOUR
DILIGENT WORK I'M HAPPY TO BE
HERE TODAY TO PRESENT AB SIXTEEN
SIXTY THREE THE PROBATE
CONSERVATORSHIP REFORM AND
SUPPORTED DECISION MAKING ACT AS
MANY OF US SAW DURING THE HIGHLY
PUBLICIZED BRITNEY SPEARS
THIRTEEN YEAR BATTLE TO
TERMINATE HER CONSERVATORSHIP.
THE SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA IS IN
DESPERATE NEED OF REFORM. THOSE
WHO AREMOST LIKELY. TO ENTER
INTO A PROBATE CONSERVATORSHIP
ARE PERSONS WITH INTELLECTUAL
AND DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
AS WELL AS THOSE WITH AGE
RELATED DISABILITIES SUCH AS
DEMENTIA OR ALZHEIMER'S. PRIOR
TO MY TIME IN THE LEGISLATURE I
CLERKED FOR SAN DIEGO SUPERIOR
COURT JUDGE WHO OVERSAW
CONSERVATIVE SHIPS. DURING THAT
TIME I SAW HOW EASY IT IS TO
ENTER A SUCH A CONSERVATORSHIP
AND HOW DIFFICULT IT IS TO
LEAVE. I SAW THE POTENTIAL FOR
ABUSE AND THE NEED FOR REFORMS I
KNOW FROM EXPERIENCE THAT THE
CIRCUMSTANCES SURROUNDING EVERY
CONSERVATORSHIP ARE VARIED AND
UNIQUE. THE DECISION TO SEEK A
CONSERVATORSHIP IS NOT AN EASY
ONE THERE ARE MANY EXAMPLES OF
CONSERVATORSHIP THAT ARE WORKING
WELL FOR EVERYONE INCLUDING THE
CONSERVATIVE AND IF THAT IS THE
CASE THIS BILL DOES ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING TO CHANGE THAT. HOWEVER
THERE ARE CONSERVATORSHIP SO
THAT ARE HARMFUL AS YOU WILL
HEAR FROM ONE OF OUR WITNESSES
TODAY OR UNNECESSARY MANY WELL
MEANING FAMILIES ENTERED.
CONSERVATORSHIP BECAUSE THEY'RE
MISTAKENLY TOLD IT IS THE ONLY
OPTION TO PROTECT THEIR LOVED
ONES. WHEN A PERSON ENTERS A
CONSERVATORSHIP ALL RIGHTS AND
LIBERTIES ARE TAKEN AWAY FROM
THEM AND PLACED IN THE CONTROL
OF THEIR CONSERVATORY. WHEN THE
COURT IS MAKING A DECISION TO
STRIP AN INDIVIDUAL OF THEIR
BASIC CIVIL LIBERTIES IT IS
ESSENTIAL THAT THIS ACTION ONLY
BE TAKEN. IF IT IS THE LAST
RESORT AB SIXTEEN SIXTY THREE
SIX TO REFORM THE PROBATE
CONSERVATORSHIP SYSTEM.
INSTITUTING A MORE THOROUGH
PROCESS AND ENSURING MEANINGFUL
ALTERNATIVES ARE RECOGNIZED AND
PRIORITIZED. FIRST IT JOINS BUT
WILL THEY BE SIXTEEN SIXTY THREE
WOULD JOIN EIGHTEEN OTHER STATES
IN RECOGNIZING SUPPORTED
DECISION MAKING AS A LESS
RESTRICTIVE ALTERNATIVE. THE
COURT MUST CONSIDER BEFORE
GRANTING A CONSERVATORSHIP.%
SUPPORTED DECISION MAKING IS A
CONCEPT THAT OUT REALLY ALL OF
US USE EVERY DAY WE A SEEK
ADVICE FROM OUR FRIENDS AND FROM
OUR FAMILY ABOUT DECISIONS.
WHETHER THEY'RE BIG OR THEIR
SMALL MAYBE BUYING A HOUSE
CHANGING CAREERS OR EVEN OUT
WHAT WE WANT TO EAT. RELYING ON
OUR TRUSTED NETWORK HELPS US TO
MAKE DECISIONS BUT ULTIMATELY WE
ARE THE ONES WHO MAKE THE
CHOICE. SUPPORTED DECISION
MAKING AFFORD THAT SAME
OPPORTUNITY TO THOSE WITH
DISABILITIES AND ALLOWS AN
INDIVIDUAL TO IDENTIFY TRUSTED
SUPPORTERS TO HELP THEM MAKE AND
COMMUNICATE DECISIONS. WHILE
PROTECTING THE RIGHTS AND
PRESERVING THEIR ABILITY TO MAKE
CHOICES AND DECISIONS FOR
THEMSELVES. NEXT AB SIXTEEN
SIXTY THREE CREATES A
CONSERVATORSHIP ALTERNATIVES
PROGRAM TO IDENTIFY
CONSERVATORSHIP PETITIONS WERE
LESS RESTRICTIVE OPTIONS MAY BE
APPROPRIATE. IT ALSO ENSURES
CONSERVATIVES MAINTAIN A CHOICE
IN THEIR LIVES BY REQUIRING
CONSERVATIVES TO CONSULT WITH
CONSERVATIVES ON DECISIONS. AND
TO MAKE DECISIONS ALIGNED WITH
CONSERVATIVES COMMUNICATED
WISHES. LASTLY AB SIXTEEN SIXTY
THREE WILL MAKE CONSERVATORSHIP
EASIER TO AND BY ENSURING
CONSERVATIES KNOW THEIR RIGHTS.
AND REQUIRE HEARINGS OF A
CONSERVATIVE REQUEST TO
TERMINATE THE CONSERVATORSHIP. I
WANT TO THANK THE BROAD
COALITION INCLUDING DISABILITY
RIGHTS ADVOCATES AGING COMMUNITY
ADVOCATES CIVIL RIGHTS ADVOCATES
IN THE FREE BRITNEY L. A.
MOVEMENT FOR THEIR ON GOING
WORK. TO MAKE THIS BILL THAT
PASSED IN THE STRONGEST IT CAN
BE. I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
MANY INDIVIDUALS WHO OF CONTACT
MY OFFICE TO PROVIDE VALUABLE
INPUT ABOUT THE LANGUAGE OF THE
BILL. AND WE HAVE WORK TO
ADDRESS MANY OF THE OPPOSITION'S
CONCERNS AB SIXTEEN SIXTY THREE
IS VITAL LEGISLATION TO PROTECT
AN INDIVIDUAL'S RIGHT TO MAKE
DECISIONS OVER THEIR LIVES. AND
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE HERE WITH ME TODAY TO SHARE
THEIR STORIES ARE VENUS YES AND
NINA SPIEGELMAN. THANKYOU. WE
HAVE BOTH WITNESSES IN THE
HEARING ROOM TODAY THE FIRST
WITNESS PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
DAY TO ALL MY NAME IS VENUS
GUEST AND I'M AN ADVOCATE FOR
PROBATE AND FAMILY COURT REFORM
IN CALIFORNIA NATION WHY. I'M A
BOARD MEMBER OF THE UNITED
SENIORS OF ALAMEDA COUNTY
APPOINTED BY THE PRESIDENT AND
BOARD OF SUPERVISOR NATE MILEY.
WHY AM I IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE
SIX SIX THREE. BECAUSE MY
PARENTS EXPERIENCE PHYSICAL OR
FINANCIAL ABUSE BY THE SUPERIOR
COURT OF ALAMEDA COUNTY IN
BERKELEY. WHEN JUDGE THOMAS
BURDEN APPOINTED A TEMPORARY
CONSERVATORSHIP NICK MACHEL
TERRON IN TO CARE FOR MY EIGHTY
FOUR YEAR OLD MOTHER WITH
DEMENTIA. INSTEAD OF PLACING HER
IN THE LOVING AND CARING HANDS
OF ME HER DAUGHTER. MY BEAUTIFUL
THRIVING MOTHER DECLINED AND
DETERIORATED NGUYEN NUMBER ONE.
THE CONSERVATORSHIP ABRUPTLY
SNATCHED MY MOTHER OUT OF A
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY WHERE
SHE WAS THRIVING WITH PHYSICAL
THERAPY MEDICAL STAFF ACTIVITIES
AND A HEALTHY DIET. THE
CONSERVATIVE WHO THEN PLACE MY
MOTHER IN AN ISOLATED SUB
STANDARD RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITY WITH NO MEDICAL
ATTENTION. AND MY MOTHER HAD
GOOD INSURANCE. NUMBER TWO. THE
CONSERVATORSHIP CONFISCATED MY
MOTHER'S CALPERS RETIREMENT AND
SOCIAL SECURITY BENEFITS THAT
WERE NOT USED FOR MY MOTHER'S
CARE AND THAT'S STILL UNDER
INVESTIGATION WITH SOCIAL
SECURITY. NUMBER THREE THE
CONSERVATOR AND HER ATTORNEY
ATTEMPTED TO SELL MY MOTHER'S.
AND MY PARENTS EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLAR RENTAL PROPERTY
TO PAY A SEVENTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLAR COURT FEES AND THE
CONSERVATIVE THREATENS THE
TENANTS TO GIVE HER THE RENTAL
INCOME. NUMBER FOUR THE CONCERT
OR GAVE MY MOTHER THREE TO SIX
MONTHS TO LIVE WHEN SHE WAS NOT
DYING SHE WAS NOT TERMINALLY
ILL. AND FOUR YEARS LATER MY MOM
SURVIVED. ON FEBRUARY FOURTEENTH
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THAT LOVE DAY
CAUGHT VALENTINE'S DAY. WE HER
FAMILY RESCUED MY MOTHER FROM
THE RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITY
AND OUT OF THE HANDS OF ALL
PUBLIC SERVANTS OF THE COURT WHO
FILLED OUR FAMILY. WE TOOK HER
HOME AND YES THE NATIONALLY
THERE WAS FAMILY CONFLICT IN
COURT BUT WE UNITED IN ENOUGH
TIME TO SAVE MY MOTHER'S LIFE
THE CONSERVATIVE JUDGE ATTORNEYS
WERE NOT HAPPY BUT MOM WAS SAFE
WE WERE HER VOICE WE BECAME HER
SUPPORTIVE DECISION MAKING TEAM.
MY MOTHER PASSED ON THANKSGIVING
DAY TWENTY TWENTY ONE FREE AT
HOME AT PEACE IN HER WARM BED
AND WITH HER LOVING FAMILY THIS
IS HOW AB ONE SIX SIX THREE
COULD AND WOULD SUPPORT THE
PEOPLE FAMILY FIRST. THANK YOU
THANK YOU WELCOME PLACE GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS NINA
SPIEGELMAN AND I'M THE POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR DISABILITY VOICES
UNITED A CO SPONSOR OF AB
SIXTEEN SIXTY THREE BUT MOST
IMPORTANT I AM A SINGLE MOTHER
OF A TWENTY SIX YEAR OLD SON
WITH AUTISM AND HIGH SUPPORT
NEEDS I AM ALSO MY SON'S
CONSERVATIVE- AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. I UNDERSTAND
THE INTENSE DESIRE BY PARENTS OF
DISABLED ADULTS WITH COMPLEX
NEEDS TO PROTECT THEIR CHILDREN
I BELIEVE THIS BILL HELPS PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES TO BE MORE
PROTECTED AS WELL AS EMPOWERED
FIRST LET ME BE CLEAR ABOUT WHAT
THIS BILL DOES NOT DO IT DOES
NOT END EXISTING PROBATE
CONSERVATORSHIP OR ABOLISHED
FUTURE CONSERVATORSHIP IT DOES
NOT TAKE AWAY THE POWER OF
CONSERVATIVES TO MAKE CHOICES
FOR THEIR CONSERVATIVE HE'S AND
IT DOES NOT REQUIRE ANYONE TO
USE SUPPORT DECISION MAKING.
HERE IS WHAT THE BILL ACTUALLY
DOES. AB SIXTEEN SIXTY THREE
ENSURES THAT CONSERVATORSHIP IS
THE LEAST RESTRICTIVE
ALTERNATIVE AS CURRENT LAW
REQUIRES. IT MAKE SURE PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES AND THEIR
FAMILIES UNDERSTAND AND CONSIDER
THE FULL RANGE OF OTHER OPTIONS
BESIDES CONSERVATORSHIP. THE
BILL PUTS ONE OF THOSE OPTIONS
SUPPORTED DECISION MAKING INTO
CALIFORNIA LAW FOR THE FIRST
TIME. IT LETS PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES CHOOSE TRUSTED
SUPPORTERS TO HELP THEM MAKE
DECISIONS. MY SON CAN BUILD A
CIRCLE OF SUPPORT HE WILL BE
AROUND LONG AFTER I AM GONE IT
WILL EMPOWER HIM TO BUILD NEW
SKILLS BY PARTICIPATING AND
PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PERSONAL GROWTH. BEYOND THE
OPPORTUNITIES IT WILL PROVIDE
FOR MY SON I SEE AB SIXTEEN
SIXTY THREE AS GROUNDBREAKING
CIVIL RIGHTS LEGISLATION. THIS
BILL SAYS THAT PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND OLDER ADULTS
SHOULD BE RESPECTED AND
EMPOWERED IT QUESTIONS THE
ASSUMPTIONS THAT THE ONLY WAY TO
PROTECT PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
IS TO STRIP AWAY ALL OF THEIR
HUMAN RIGHTS. IT SAYS
CONSERVATORSHIP SHOULD BE RARE
AND THE LAST RESORT. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN FOR
BEING SUCH AN INCREDIBLE
CHAMPION FOR THE DISABILITY
COMMUNITY WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU TO PASS THIS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT CIVIL
RIGHTS BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WHO WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE
SUPPORT FOR A BI SIXTEEN SIXTY
THREE. WE WILL TAKE ANY FURTHER
TESTIMONY WHAT IF YOU COULD GIVE
YOUR NAME YOUR AFFILIATION. AND
YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL- VERY
HELPFUL FROM. WE CONFIRMED
ADVOCATING FOR INCLUSION YEAH
RIGHT THE REQUESTED RIGHT THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING SORRY BRANDON
CRONE SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
IN THE HEARING ROOM IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT
FOR A BI SIXTEEN SIXTY THREE AND
AGAIN WE'RE NOT TAKING ANY
FURTHER TESTIMONY BUT JUST NAME
AFFILIATION. AND POSITION ON THE
BILL. TO EXPRESS SUPPORT PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. OUR
FIRST LINE WILL BE OPENING THE
LINE FIFTY FIVE GO AHEAD PLEASE
. GOOD MORNING CHAIRED MEMBERS
THIS IS ERIC HARRIS WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA HAS
STRONG SUPPORT CO SPONSORS OF
THE BILL THANK YOU. NINE FIFTY
THREE. BOB GOOD MORNING CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MARK PLANTS
AN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY LIVING
NETWORK A STATEWIDE TRADE
ORGANIZATION OF OVER ONE HUNDRED
AGENCY PROVIDERS LARGE AND SMALL
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF.
NINE THIRTY ONE. GOOD MORNING
JONATHAN GO NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN SIXTY
THREE THANK YOU. NINE FIFTY ONE.
HELLO GO AHEAD PLEASE WE CAN
HEAR YOU. OKAY HI- MY NAME MY
NAME IS MARIE BERGERON I AM A
SELF ADVOCATE WAS SUPPORTED
DECISION MAKING AND THE BILL A.
B. ONE SIX SIX THREE. PROVIDE
SUPPORT THE BILL PERFECT THANK
YOU. NINE SIXTY ONE. MORNING
CUTIE MARK THE NON SURGICAL
OPTIONS ON THE PRACTICE THAT THE
COURT DECISION MAKING A CRACK IN
A DISABILITY VOICES UNITED IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN
FIFTY TECH. NINE FIFTY SEVEN.
HELLO THIS IS- KAREN COLES AND
THE PIRATES OF THE SEVENTEEN
YEAR OLD DOWN SYNDROME HE
PLANNED TO USE THE COURTS TO
MAKING AND CALLING ON BEHALF OF
PALESTINE THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
CASH WE STRONG SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU. BY SIXTY. MONICA
RAINY ASK FAMILY AS AN ADULT
WHAT THE DEVELOPMENT DISABILITY
I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB.
SIXTEEN SIXTY THREE. LINE FIFTY
SIX. ONE MOMENT PLEASE PROVIDE
BUT LIKE FIFTY SIX HAS DROPPED
OUT OF QUEUE LINE SIXTEEN. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS TONY CHECK A
TELE BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES FOR NURSING HOME
REFORM WE'RE PROUD TO BE A CO
SPONSOR OF AB SIXTEEN SIXTY
THREE AND- ARE STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT. LINE. SIXTY THREE. GOOD
MORNING COMING BY MARCH PARENTS
OF NON CONSERVED AUTISTIC ADULTS
WITH COMPLEX SUPPORT NEEDS WHO
PRACTICES SUPPORTED DECISION
MAKING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
SIXTEEN SIXTY THREE THANK YOU.
LINE SIXTY TWO. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS AND HERZL DISABILITY
RIGHTS ADVOCATE AND
COMMUNICATIONS AND DEVELOPMENT
COORDINATOR FOR DISABILITY
UNITED IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
SIXTEEN SIXTY THREE. WE HAVE ONE
MORE QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT WHILE
THE PROVIDER LINE NUMBER. FIND
SIXTY NINE GO AHEAD PLEASE. HI
MY NAME IS KILL THE HIT ON A
PARENT OF A CHILD THAT RECEIVES
REGIONAL CENTER SERVICES I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB ONE SIX SIX
THREE. THANK YOU. MR HERE WE
HAVE NO FURTHER LINE'S QUEUED UP
. THANK YOU WE WILL NOW THEN
MOVED TO OPPOSITION I DO NOT
HAVE ANY OPPOSITION WITNESSES
LISTED BUT IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO AB
SIXTEEN SIXTY THREE. ALLRIGHT
SEE NONE. OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB. SIXTEEN SIXTY
THREE. IF YOU TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE MOMENT
WHILE WE PROVIDE THEIR LINE
NUMBERS. FIRST GO TO LINE
SEVENTY GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING MISTER TURNER MEMBER
THREE TO ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF
THE ARK AND UNITED TERRIBLE
PALSY CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION
WE DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON THE
BILL YEAH AND WE REALLY JUST
WANTED TO CALL IN AND SAY WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE-
TO ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS SO-
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NINE
TWENTY SEVEN. GOOD MORNING JERRY
MEMBERS THIS IS JERRY DOES LAND
ON BEHALF OF PROFESSIONAL THE
NEW SHEARY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA BUT WE HAVE NOT
SUBMITTED A FORMAL OPPOSITION
LETTER AS WE ARE ENGAGED IN
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE OFFICE
OFFICE AND THE PROPONENTS AND
WANTS TO MAKE SURE TO POINT OUT
THAT WE DO. SUPPORT OR TO
DECISION MAKING AT THE
CONSERVATORSHIP ALTERNATIVE. AND
WE COULD GET BUT THAT WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE RESERVATIONS
WITH SEVERAL OF THE PROVISIONS
OF THE BILL IS THE PASSAGE YOU
COMMITTEE. AND BELIEVE WITH
FURTHER REVISIONS OF THIS COULD
BE A PROCESS THAT WOULD WORK TO
ENSURE. THAT IT IS NOT AN
IMPEDIMENT TO THE SUCCESSFUL
ADMINISTRATION OF COURT IMPOSED
CONSERVATORSHIP PROCEEDINGS.
REPORTER FOR THE CONVERSATION
AND THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NINE
SIXTY FIVE. NINE SIXTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD PLEASE. HI
MY NAME IS JOSELYN LINEUP I AM
UP AND- US THE CELL KILLED WE-
WILL POLICY AND ALSO I'VE- AT
BEACH FOR THE MODERATE TO SEVERE
. AND MY COMMODITY AND MY
BROTHER IS GOING TO. I AM LUCKY
IN. VOCAL FAIR BUT THE- I DON'T
KNOW DO WE HAVE TO NEW SIXTEEN
THREE SO I DON'T IT. EVERYTHING
IS IN LINE. I WITH IT. I AM THE
TEACHER IN THE PROJECT INCOME
FOR STUDENTS AND RETAIN THAT. I
DO THAT BE FOR ALL EVERYTHING.
EVERY IS DIFFERENT SO I DON'T.
WITH THIS PICK. THANK YOU NINE
FIFTY NINE- HELLO MY NAME IS ALL
IF SHE KNOWS I AM A FAN MAN OF A
LEAGUE THE STATE OLD ADULTS AND
POTENTIAL AFTER FOR CONSERVATIVE
. AYE OPPOSED- A. B. C. SIXTY
TWO THANK YOU THANK YOU. PINE TO
FIVE. HOW MY NAME IS MAKES I AM
A MOTHER OF A ADULT FUN WITH
SEVERE AND CALL ON BEHALF DOCTOR
OF FIVE CAMP BAY AREA IN STRONG
. OF. SIXTEEN THREE. WE DO HAVE
A FEW MORE LINES IN Q. ONE
MOMENT WHILE THE PROVIDER LINE
NUMBERS.
NINE FORTY EIGHT. HELLO MY NAME
IS IRENE LET HER LAN AND I AM
THE PARENT OF A YOUNG ADULT WITH
AUTISM AND I AM IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL THANK YOU. LINE. SIXTY
EIGHT. SIXTY EIGHT GO AHEAD
PLEASE. HELLO GO AHEAD PLEASE.
HELLO AM I BEING HEARD YES WE
CAN HEAR YOU. OKAY I DON'T KNOW
WHAT LINE I WAS MY NAME IS
DEBORAH DARDEN I AM THE SINGLE
PARENT OF A AND B. TOLD SIGN.
WITH AUTISM AND I AM AGAINST
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
LINE. THIRTY HI MY NAME IS
MARYLAND CREDIBLE AND I AM WITH
THE PROFESSIONAL FIDUCIARY
SEARCHES A PROFESSIONAL. WHILE
WE DO NOT HAVE AN- ABSOLUTE
POSITION YET ON THIS BILL WE DO
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT SOME OF THE
PROVISIONS IN THE BILL AS IT
RELATES TO CONFLICTS THAT WE SEE
BETWEEN A CERTAIN DECISION
MAKING AND CONSERVATIVE
PROCEEDINGS- YOU KNOW THAT WE DO
SUPPORT ALTERNATIVES TO
CONSERVATORSHIP AND THE ABILITY
OF INDIVIDUALS RIGHT TO
TERMINATE THEM AND- THEY ARE
HOPING THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
WORK BUT THE OFFICE OFFICE JUST
MOVED OUT OF THESE. ISSUES THAT
WE THINK THANK YOU. LINE FIFTY
EIGHT. YEAH I DID. HELLO HELLO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD. OKAY
THIS IS- JOSHI I AND MY PARENTS
ARE FIVE AN ADULT- MODERATELY
AFFECTED BY AUTISM AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL AT LEAST BILL SEEMS
LIKE IT IS- THANK YOU ARE NONE
OF THAT FOR THEIR YEARS OF LAW
DON'T CARE JUST IN EUROPE IS
PERFECT THANK YOU. WE HAVE NOT
LINES IN CUBA'S CHAIRMAN GO AT.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU OPERATOR I
WILL BRING THIS BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE THAT AND THANK YOU MR
MAIENSCHEIN FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. THESE ARE DIFFICULT
ISSUES THESE ARE THESE ARE
PARENTS AND LOVED ONES WHO ARE.
DOING ABSOLUTELY THEIR BEST. FOR
THEIR LOVED ONES AND PEOPLE WHO
ARE. CHALLENGED AND THAT'S WHERE
YOU'RE HEARING SOME OF THE
MOTION HERE BUT- I THINK AS WE
BRING FORWARD TO GET MORE
SOPHISTICATED OF POLICY. THE
MORE TOOLS WE CAN GIVE IN THESE
SITUATIONS. THE BETTER FOR THOSE
WHO ARE BEING CARED FOR. AND
WITH CONSERVATORSHIP SINCE OF
THAT STRUCTURE. BEING THE LAST
RESORT AND THE MORE WE CAN HELP.
FAMILIES DEAL WITH AND SET UP.
MORE APPROPRIATE STRUCTURES FOR
DECISION MAKING. THE BETTER SO I
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE WORK
THAT YOU'RE DOING HERE THE WILL
YOUR WILLINGNESS TO TAKE THIS ON
. OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. ALL RIGHT
CIGNA JUST MAKE SURE YOU MAKE
CLOSE WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OF MISTER CHAIR BRITNEY SPEARS
HAD THE BENEFIT OF WORLDWIDE
FAME TO SHINE A LIGHT ON HER
CASE BUT THE REALLY SO MANY
OTHERS WHO ARE TRAPPED IN THE
SAME SYSTEM THAT STRIPS THEM OF
THEIR IDENTITY AB SIXTEEN SIXTY
THREE IS ABOUT EXTENDING A VOICE
TO THOSE WITHOUT THAT SAME
PLATFORM I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU I'M
LOOKING FOR A MOTION ON AB
SIXTEEN SIXTY THREE. K. WE DO
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND THAT
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE AYE STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I.
DAVIES. DAVIES I HOLDEN. HOLDEN
AYE KALRA KALRA AYE KILEY. KILEY
AYE MAIENSCHEIN AYE MAIENSCHEIN
AYE REYES. REYES I RIVAS. RIVAS
AYE WICKS AYE WICKS AYE. GREAT
THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE
EVERYONE HERE SO LET'S ROLL
THROUGH. THE AGENDA AND CATCH
FOLKS UP WE DO HAVE A COUPLE OF
BILLS ON CALL SO BUT LET'S START
WITH THE CONSENT AGENDA CALL THE
ABSENT. MEMBERS DAVIES. DAVIES I
HOLDEN. HOLDEN I KILEY. KILEY I
WICKS WEBSITE. RATES WILL NOW
MOVE TO I NUMBER ONE WHICH
ALREADY HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO BE
BUT CALL THE UP MEMBERS THIS IS
AJ ARE TWENTY THREE
BOERNER HORVATH- I'M SORRY WE
DIDN'T GET EMOTIONAL SECOND ON
AJ ARE TWENTY. SECOND OKAY SO WE
DO NOW HAVE MOTION SECOND THAT
MOTION IS THAT H. A. R. TWENTY
THREE BE ADOPTED CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE AYE STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I.
DAVIES. DAVIES I HOLDEN. HOLDEN
AYE KALRA. KALRA AYE KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
REYES REYES AYE RIVAS. RIVAS AYE
WICKS LOOKS I. OKAY ITEM NUMBER
TWO AB SIXTEEN SIXTY SIX POWER
QUE HAND IS ON CALL I'M GOING TO
LIFT THE CALL. DAVIES AB IS NO
HOLDEN HOLDEN I KILEY. KILEY NO
WICKS WIXII THAT BILL IS OUT AB
EIGHTEEN THIRTY SEVEN BONTA IS
OUT BUT CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
PLEASE DAVIES DAVIES NO HOLDEN
HOLDEN AYE KILEY KILEY COMING UP
KILEY NO WICKES WICK SITE THANK
YOU ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB SIXTEEN
EIGHTY SIX BRIAN IS ON CALL I'M
GOING TO LIFT THE CALL. DAVIES
DAVIES NO REYES. AS I. WICKES
WICKES. THANK YOU AND I THINK A
LOT OF FIGHT WE HAVE EVERYBODY.
ALL RIGHTS I THINK THAT'S IT FOR
TODAY THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH
AND WE ARE THE GERMANS.